It was a great place I remembered as an undergraduate
it was of romantic fun kind of
exciting somewhat naughty place
but
architecturally it's quite significant the building
was built by Warren and Wetmore
about 1900, somewhere in that range.
the very famous architects who went on to build
grand central station
they designed this thing with two huge working
baronial fireplaces
skylights so it was all lit during the day
there was trellis on the Wall, big palms,
gigantic wooden beams over the pool and the
water
flowed out into the pool from of be river head
god mouth.
Essentially what happened is that they
discovered that it had a crack in it
and when they drained it for a routine
cleaning they found that it had been leaking
water and so at that time it was decided to
convert it to a theatre.
The architecture of this space
is, I've never seen anything like it before,
I mean it's obviously built in a pool, but that just
changes a bit the dynamic of the theatre.
They did fill out the bottom
of the pool a little bit so it's not completely sunken,
however it is stadium seating so it does
slope downwards towards the stage.
and the stage is sunken a little bit, I'd say perhaps
about a good
four feet
so yeah it does have an interesting
effect in that way.
Both my co director and I really liked what we
saw the space as being able to do
and we also felt that this was something that actually was
working out even better than we thought when we first saw the space.
It does work as a theatre space
but
as a architectural space, as an Edwardian architectural space
it really is unique.
I think it's one of the things that all of the
alumni from Adam's remember
as being sort of one of the signature things of
the house